For some reason or another unetbootin doesn't seem to have succeeded in correctly writing the operating system to this disk
So we're [going] try again over here [and] each quickly open up some things. I'll comment the commands of Tom and
Unetbootin didn't work some reason, but that's kind of convenient because I gets the opportunity to show how to this process from Linux situations
From Bunter, which is what we're going to school today
Has the Linux Kernel and then for the window for the graphics manager for what you interact with?
You have what's called unity and then for a package manager
Which is how you download your software essentially like a kind of more basic app store you have aptitude
So that's kind of the three main components of a linux operating system, nowadays anyway
you have the Kernel the window manager and your package manager those are the primary components at differentiate a pack a
distribution for the end user those are the ones that people typically choose their distribution on there's various other bits that can be changed and
There's lots that can be tweaked enough in a distribution
But those are the primary concerns you might use to have windows
you want a new piece [of] [software] you want to put [a]
Program to open a certain file you have to go troll in Google find download link download it and install it
Whereas package managers will kind of app stores before app stores existed you just open a package manager find what you want
One-Click installation it downloads the perfect one for your machine. Don't worry about choosing the right download don't [program] viruses
It's all verified and you get your software
So we're going to use this dish using a key model and utility called DD
Which will let us extract the I socialist disk and hopefully have some success
[I] don't know the points of my head, so I'm go to copy/paste in this page
so it's really easy to get the commands to do this and
Lots we've done for for lots of available [licenses] from the inventor forum at burn an iso to USB device the DD command requires
two parameters
and so we need to have the iso which were writing to it and we need to have the mount point of the device so
The mount point is the directory in the filesystem Earth devices mounted, so it's quite a arcane looking
Piece of information, and it's quite difficult to find additional commands
But we can use gpArted which is a graphical user interface application to really easily find that so we can see here that it's four
Slash DEV [Fourths] f for
S [Db]. So we'll whack that in and we've already got the iso in there. So now if I do that
according [to] my past I
Think I run the command without any output so I'm now just going to sit here and wait
Hope that's working the [DD] command unless you give it the option to do so doesn't the spiny diagnostics
And I didn't give it that command
So I'm now sitting here hoping and praying that it is actually in fact doing what it should be doing
We've written the DD with the stick and I've just check to see if it's working so better plugged it in
change the blue option to USB
and your ids sorry on so on this machine so not on our dictum and
Plugged in change the Built-in usB and it went free to boot fine boot up into a [bun] [t]
and when it first boots it presents you an option if you want to try bun - so run extra off the stick or whether
you want to install it and so now we're going to have the moment of truth and
Try it on the patient